darauf youtube derzeit sehr viele sims
videos hochgeladen werden habe ich mich
nach einer alternative umgeschaut und
habe mono gefunden meine damen und
herren ich glaube keiner kennt das wir
klicken einfach mal auf anmelden und
sehen schon wähle deinen morio er da ich
natürlich von frecher bin würde ich
sagen ich nehme natürlich den frischen
boy als erstes können wir hier auswählen
die seiner hautfarbe ist der sieht mehr
auf jeden fall schon mal sehr ähnlich
weil den augen habe ich natürlich grüne
augen jeder weiß das glaube ich hoffe
ich habe technisch würde ich sagen dass
die die wir gerade haben eigentlich
schon relativ gut passt
ja jetzt schöner
wir gehen natürlich wieder zurück zu den
normalen haare nicht ob sie sehen hier
schon am ähnlichsten
bei den t shirts weiß ich gar nicht
genau welches ich dann nehmen soll ich
glaube wir nehmen einfach mal hier das
hier von einem affen
ich finde auch geklappt dafür falls ihr
euch übrigens partners mumie ist das ist
quasi so wie sims nun scheiße
ihm mache wenn jetzt immer auf die hose
klicken würde ich sagen haben jetzt hier
so ein paar verschiedene ich würde sagen
wir nehmen einfach mal so eine art die
das sporthose hier der freust du dich
bei den schuhen könnten eigentlich
direkt die flip flops sind wir sicher
nicht ganz cool außer in unserer mobilen
jetzt fertig das heißt als nächstes gibt
einen monitor einen namen ich würde
sagen ich nenne ihn einfach luca
kartoffel was dieser name ist bereits
vergeben
das hier unten ist das passwort und das
ist der mumien name das heißt da
überlege ich mir meinen kurzen namen
mein name ist jetzt luca markt pizza
europa willkommen of mobimo komm ich
zeig dir alle sehr genau oder andere bio
streicheltiere bekomme diamanten noch
mehr da oben wir das menü da können wir
drauf klicken dann haben wir
verschiedene möglichkeiten hier geht es
zum shop dass es unser shop doors 2000
diamanten und kleidung zu kaufen welcher
look steht dir das heißt wir nehmen
natürlich hier erstmal nehmen doch kann
ich nicht dass kadi anklicken hier unten
sehe ich jetzt shirts eingeblendet und
nein
klingt mal wieder auf das menü und gehen
mal wieder hier an den start lass dein
profil kannst du den anderen von dir
erzielen klick auf den stiftern erzählt
etwas über dich
ich bin cool ihr nicht ich bin so
sympathisch speichern
dann können wir hier noch ein foto
reinpacken meine raumbild
a
jetzt kann ich ein bild von mir einladen
es ist keine tierquälerei sind keine
unheimlichen bilder alles gut ist ein
foto von mir und max von vor ein paar
jahren leichter freundin emily hat mich
im auto mein gott was heißt das denn
wenn du kannst nicht mit apple ist es
jetzt ein echter mit diesem macht ich
habe jetzt hier zwei tütchen bekommen da
sind 16 diamanten drin und noch mal ein
bisschen ich habe
er kann seine schnauze halten jetzt hier
krieg jetzt auf emily und jetzt sehen
wir mal emily man alles klar bei dir ist
schön dass du hier bist mein bester
freund lukas und ich halt nicht im
alltag der emmely werden echter mensch
mir scheissegal was emily er sagt hier
oben steht nur eins das heißt ich kann
emily beziehungsweise irgendwem kann ich
jetzt hier so ein ding senden ich würde
sagen ich weiß dass mein speed girlie
diesem level 1 zu ob war weiter geht's
hier meine damen und herren ich sage mal
wieder auf das menü was habe ich denn
sonst noch
wir haben hier noch ein paar sachen
diese beiträge sind von allen - auch von
denen mit denen du nicht befreundet bist
das hier sind sachen die leute gepostet
haben wer errät wie viele dinge ich
anhabe bekommt den regenbogen mol
wer errät wie viele dinge ich kann jetzt
hier im beitrag an alle posten das heißt
ich bin cool und ihr nicht
hahaha hund so posten hätte ich mir
selbst ein psg mine life hey von wem
wohl von mir ich hoffe hier hat nach
einer meinung gefragt er da würde ich
sagen kommentieren war einfach mal die
comdirect schon kommentaren nicht zum
angeblich direkt anschreiben direkt
darunter nicht so machen ich nur ich bin
schön schreibe ich mir darunter posten
ich weiß schon ich finde hier freunde
der polizistin musste ich kümmere mich
darum dass jeder hier spaß hat diese
gebiete morio regeln durch ja kommen hdf
jetzt kann ich nicht irgendwie du kannst
wieso kann ich mir mit keinem chatten
hey ich bin der linke minow fake 13 bord
der sun süßer boiler schöne gesicht hier
ich klicke jetzt einfach mal auf ihn
drauf und jetzt muss ich mit ihm
befreundet sein damit wir chatten können
also ich klicke jetzt einfach mal auf
seinem profil nur pendler klick jetzt
einfach mal hier auf als freunde zufügen
senden diesen wir uns doch einfach mal
die bio von japan dadurch nur 13
strong blue eyes single
und das ist seine wohnung oder was ist
denn die beiträge von noah hätte noch so
ein hübsches bild von sich hochgeladen
sydney 13 da ist auch schon wieder da
sitzt du auch wieder hier sitzt da
wieder da sitzt er wieder da steht er
jetzt mal das ist er wieder da steht er
auch jo harlow ist echt ein hammer
leistungsprofil hierauf moment ich habe
hier oben gerade sondern so einen bums
hier rein bekommen also hier steht was
ist jetzt gerade low sweet bowie hat
deine beitrag computer klicken einfach
mal drauf was ich so geschrieben haben
ok dann sei da schreibt einer und das
freut mich hh katze ist ein fischpass
die secude bei hat meine
freundschaftsanfrage angenommen oh mein
gott er hat neu geschrieben hahaha
antworte ich einfach mal freunde wir
schreiben gerade mit echten menschen
beim mio alter was geht ab ich denke
jetzt hier oben weil einfach auf die
stadt fünf bzw das hier so ein paar
andere leute mal angezeigt werden
ich frage mich schon direkt leute ob sie
mit mir befreundet sein können habe ich
doch direkt sagen ja nämlich an und wir
chatten es mal mit vitali dichte vitali
klitschko der boxer jetzt einfach mal
erstmal müssen wir mein profil noch ein
bisschen aufpimpen die orientieren uns
da natürlich an dem lieben noah und
schreiben jetzt mal 13 04 steckt da noch
mal den den hashtag luca shop.de
schreibe ich auch noch jetzt geht man
einfach mal auf speichern hier
vitali hat geschrieben nein ich bin
nicht noch nie von gehört
vitali natürlich bist du da schickt man
einfach mal ab acom vitality keine
ahnung die können wir uns einfach mal
auf momo klicken dann können wir ebenso
eine erdbeere senden hat er allerdings
nicht verdient weil dafür muss ich ja
selbst auch bezahlen haben was habe ich
hier das ist freundschaft private erst
mal auf seine nächste nachricht ab nur
wenige minuten später und schreibst du
nein okay was antworten wir denn dann
wie ich heiße einfach nur widerlich okay
okay so wie gott freunde mögen wer hat
schon die krise das ist einfach nur
komplett kaká
naja was heißt ich eigentlich mein
bruder vitali ich bin jetzt die
freundschaft all das kann so nicht
weitergehen
das lasse sich auch vom ersten teil von
mir noch ein zweiter haben wollt dann
schreibt beim mio in die kommentare
schaffen wir 40.000 likes meine damen
und herren würde mich sehr freuen
die hat mir sehr viel spaß gemacht die
wechsel haben wir der nächsten folge mio
dann noch weitere freunde gefunden
eventuell als vitali wieder als freunde
zugefügt eventuelles vitali dann endlich
auch mal boxer geworden und sonst würde
ich jetzt sagen ja die ausschau die
haben wir wieder alle geschrieben
das war's jetzt
video hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr sohn abonnent sein
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]